mais nathalie m'a appris à ne pas avoir
peur du mot cancer parce que je me
souvienne lectez rentrer à la maison tu
ne dis bon ben j'ai à petit budget je
dis quoi la petite bébête r c'est un
cancer cinq ans c'est quand même la
première fois nathalie m'a dit quand
même à ne pas avoir peur du mot parce
qu'elle ben a souffert d'un cancer très
grave il ya quelques années ça l'avait
sorti il ya 20 ans jour pour jour on
discute en quelque part au musée de
l'auto de mulhouse elle m'a parlé du
cancer après faut qu'on me parlait
ouvertement du cancer elle m'a appris
qu'il fallait le voir en face à l'as
écrit d'ailleurs un livre qui s'appelle
cancer en phase pour regarder la maladie
en face pour mieux la combattre et c'est
vrai que tous les médecins disent que le
font des efforts font des recherches
fondées j'admire mais bon c'est mon les
médecins qui m'ont soigné et qui soigne
tous des malades du cancer mais le
malade lui-même et doit aussi essayer de
garder la pêche que garder la pêche qui
vous le dis souvent c'est 40 à 50% de la
guerre plus peut-être pour ça sert voilà
donc ne pas avoir peur du mot française
mais celui là quand même poumon j'ai
toujours pensé que ça ne pouvait arriver
qu'aux autres certains fument et gallas
s'est soigné comme un pompier c'est
combien de deux baquets sport et je m
entends tu as well et donc vous avez
arrêté oui il ya bien arrêtées alors ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est que je
pensais que c'était impossible d'arrêter
de fumer physiquement je n'arrivais j'ai
arrêté deux heures de fumée j'avais
envie de fumer comme tous les gros
fumeurs j'y arriverai pas j'y ai peur va
arrêter de fumer et moi j'ai arrêté de 5
de 17 juin jour où mon chirurgien m'a
dit bon aller fumer plus parce que je ne
mens pas au jeu peut pas opérer un
fumeur parce qu'il ya trop de risques
d'infection de ce jour là j'ai
d'abord avec un patch pendant quinze
jours jusqu'à la date de mon opération
j'ai été opéré le 5 juillet je n'ai pas
fumé depuis le 17 juin et après le 5
juillet je n'ai jamais remis ni patch
avait pas besoin j'ai pas envie de fumer
donc on peut arrêter de fumer à quoi
vous il faut juste armée de volonté en
fait c'est ça l'histoire et vous
nathalie quand il vous parle de la
petite bête sous-entendu le cancer vous
réagissez comme ans à ce moment là bas
je sais qu'il a vu que j'ai pas fait la
même tête alors j'ai pas fait la même
tête du tout par rapport à la prostate
parce que cancer des poumons c'est quand
même violent mais
mais je me suis dis bah façon on n'a pas
le choix il on va se battre et puis on
va y arriver parce qu'il n'a pas le
choix il est obligé la deux enfants
derrière elle à sa petite femme donc il
n'a pas l'air de nous lâcher donc
ces planteurs du jean pierre donc c'est
interdit sinon je l'étranglé
et non puis
on a des médecins extraordinaire de la
technique technologie extraordinaire les
enfants ils sont dans lequel ils sont
dans le même état d'esprit que vous
c'est à dire qu'il est sur les épaules
et il en va se battre oui évidemment bon
après je suis pas avec eux s'il pleure
dans leur chambre où ça je ne sais pas
mais
je leur ment jamais dont je dis chaque
femme chaque étape comment ça se passe
quels sont les résultats donc ils savent
qu'ils peuvent me faire confiance et si
vraiment faire attention parce que des
fois il ya des médecins aussi qui dit
vous avez plus qu un mois à vivre les
deux mois avait fait attention moi j'ai
plein de messages j'ai reçu plein de
messages où on a dit ça certaines
personnes et ça fait quatre ans ils sont
encore là bien sûr donc la sanction
ridicule pour voilà exactement même
s'ils ont été malades aussi en 98 qu'on
ne donnait pas moi non mais j'ai ma
pioche en ce moment j'ai un médecin
n'ont pas de pronostic
le traitement et on verra après donc les
taton sont en cours pour faire a dit
pour l'instant il ya un premier pas vers
tumeur qui est parti à pour l'opérer
merci aux chirurgiens qui a des doigts
pour eux c'est avec une vidéo où ils
sont géniaux tout le monde est génial
parce que quand on se plaint dans un
hôpital vous êtes une infirmière ou une
dame qui fait le ménage tué le chauffeur
noro
damas côté le souffre davantage que ol
aura plus de sourire elle regonfle les
gens ils ont le personnel hospitalier il
est formidable ils sont mises en plein
de boulot il manque de moyens on sait
qu'ils font des services qui sont vie
normale ils sont crevés mais ils sont là
pour aider des malades et puis les
médecins qui se battent c'est fabuleux
mais sur le regard des gens il ya
quelque chose de différent quand j'ai
dit que j'avais un cancer de la prostate
plein de gens m'ont téléphoné en zohra
toi aussi mais avec un petit sourire
encore et du style ouais campagne
approche un peu comment ça va se passer
pour vous mais bon bref de quoi tu as
pris plutôt rigoler à ce moment-là
cancer du poumon les gens répondent pas
la même chose les gens de répondre oh
merde